For Thought leadership stuff the editing
is not the biggest piece the first
minute really really matters if you're
doing thought leadership like direct to
camera the first sentence you say really
matters it's hooking people in for the
first minute just like you would on a
landing page a website an email like the
sentence matters the first paragraph
matters to help people to want to watch
the rest of it so it depends on what you
want to sell if you want to sell
speaking engagements and speaking
Services then they need to see you speak
and just start speaking just like hit me
with something what do you believe that
other people don't believe you don't
need fancy editing for that it's quality
of thought more than quality of
production but in a lot of speeches it's
still slow to get into it it's still
like or even like worse of the intros
hey I'm Evan and I do yada yada like
goodbye nobody's watching that it's like
right away into your powerful opinion or
you do coaching where you're helping
people who have productivity issues or
whatever else you want to coach people
on and they come on and they share what
they're struggling with and you coach
them through it editing is if you were
to ask me in five years it might be
slightly different it's starting to pick
up but they're not watching your videos
because there's a main climbing a rock
in California with the sunrise behind
you with some fancy music they're
watching your videos because they're
there to learn something
Larry French welcome man I'm very new at
this even though I've had a channel for
a long time I just I do horsemanship I
teach people how to ride and I work with
uh problem horses okay but so what I've
been doing is just basically putting
videos on there so that people can can
see it uh but I'm like I said I'm very
new and I I was in that deal you had
last week and could you help me with
with the data as far as what I need to
be looking at
and Impressions I don't know what
Impressions means so I always start with
this actually like what do you want to
sell so you're selling are you selling
coaching for well you're helping like
people come to your Ranch and they're
gonna learn how to horseback ride you're
gonna coach them over Zoom you have
digital programs you're selling what are
you actually selling yeah we have uh
some digital uh programs that we're
going to be selling and also I've
started a membership site I'm getting
older so riding is something that that
gets hard on me like it's hard for me to
do every day so we're trying to do which
we have been doing we've been we do a
lot of Facebook lives and working with
people across the country where we don't
where they don't have to come to us but
we do occasionally have a clinic here
okay great so some of the best content
honestly is even just showing what what
um
your students have questions about and
doing interviews with them and where
they interview you and they're asking
questions and you help them well I mean
the uh the dad as far as uh like um
you know how many people were like the
views I know what views means but there
last week you were talking about it was
the data the added data uh you were
telling us things that we need to look
for
um
I can't even think of one that one now
right now with blank uh yeah no worries
okay so let me pull up I'll pull up like
uh I'll pull up my gaming channel I've
been posting here in a long time let me
show you just what an example would be
okay so this is a tiny channel
uh all like really short nothing content
but it's still kind of the same layout
and overview right so if I click on this
this is where you're gonna get to this
is your channel back end overview
okay you want to click on the see more
here
okay and then I'll I like going to 90
days especially on a smaller channel so
you can see more content
and then what it's going to show you is
how many views how many watch hours how
many subscribers Revenue Impressions and
click-through rate so these are the
impressions
okay so what you would do then if you're
looking at updating your potential
thumbnails and titles on videos of when
what ones are have high leverage to be
able to fix you can see when I sort
through Impressions now you can see a
lot of these videos have all fallen off
because I haven't posted content right
so I stopped posting content on this
channel around here September and so now
nothing's happening because I'm not
posting content so you know okay a
lesson in consistency if I wanted to
keep this channel going
um but in here you can see by sorting by
impressions
what we want to do is try to find
similar
similar ranges of Impressions so the six
thousand six thousand six thousand five
thousand four thousand these are all
kind of similar
and try to see which ones are
underperforming so
some of them here we've got even got
three percent but some of these are
really bad point eight percent point
eight percent point nine percent
so these should be fixed
okay so this is a this is a a sign now
most of these thumbnails I don't think
we even put any effort into it right
okay so this was our this was a this was
a test right a Tech Challenge test this
is a live stream you know so this
the live streams are terrible on the
click-through rate this one where we
actually put more up into the thumbnail
did better so even looking at this right
this one did three percent and we put a
thumbnail on it with text and
um a picture and the one above it
similar number of Impressions was a
moment it was a tech challenge for a
contest uh
um we're running momentum challenge we
just did a quick tech chat at the
beginning and so uh that's not like this
shouldn't even be really a public video
on the channel right and then you look
above and this one is this was a live
stream that's for an hour and 18 minutes
and guide a lot of Impressions but the
thumbnail
is not great because it's just a live
stream and we should we if we wanted to
make this video do well we should put a
a thumbnail on it like this
um okay so why that matters is in
looking at these three videos so this
has
2 800 Impressions 3 500 Impressions 4
800 impressions
right so this one is is almost double
the impressions as this one
right if we go like five thousand and
three thousand it's it's not quite
double but almost double but if you look
at the views
this one has 128 views and this has 56
views
because it has a higher click-through
rate
because the thumbnail is better
okay now these could be I mean these are
tiny numbers this could be 12 000 or 12
million right these all it all scales up
so the key is you're sorting by
Impressions and then seeing similar
videos
by Impressions what has a lower
click-through rate
and that means you should go fix that
like this one is the worst one here
point seven percent this this really
sucks
and again it's just it's just my live
stream
thumbnail we didn't update it to a real
thumbnail
but this is low hanging fruit like in
the past 90 days it got six almost seven
thousand impressions
but only 72 views
because it has a really bad
click-through rate now what could fix a
click-through rate well we should have a
name on it
like the name of the videos Evan plays
games and takes your questions that's
not a great name
and then the thumbnail doesn't it just
says ask Evan live so there's no real
reason to want to click on the video
so you can all just do this for your own
channel just again to find it you're on
your back end here your analytics so you
start on dashboard this is where you'll
log in you click Analytics
and then you click see more
and then I just like switching it to 90
days to get more data on smaller
channels
and then you can sort by impression it
defaults to sort by views but you can
sort by Impressions what this means is
YouTube is trying to show these videos
they're saying hey please we're trying
to show these These are good videos we
like these videos but nobody's clicking
on them
so they're basically begging me to like
please fix these fix this fix fix this
especially this one like fix this point
seven percent
you know fix some of these videos you
have to have so many views for uh for
YouTube to to show your videos or to
no I mean I I pulled up a tiny Channel
just to show because it gives a great
demo like even on this small Channel
if I could take this from a 0.7
click-through rate to a three which
we've already done
right if I can you know four times how
much I'm getting from a video like at
four times my views on that video Plus
okay so you know in pulling up your
Channel
we got 680 subscribers that's that's
great the first 680 is the hardest 680.
play we're going
and then you can see what's done well
some of these have done well so longer
form videos are crushing right like your
longest form your your longest video is
also your best video of the ones that
you've posted yeah 31 minutes versus all
these other ones that are shorter that
aren't getting as many views so people
love learning and if they want to learn
how to
if they want to learn how to calm a
bucking horse where are they going like
they're not going to the library so they
can find Larry French on YouTube
that's right so uh this is where like
people are going to learn
um I would I would put your face
somewhere here like you can't your Hat's
covering your face completely and it's
just like some some guy on a on a horse
you know so that could be if we're
building our personal brand to be Larry
French great to see Larry French and
honestly all of these could have better
thumbnails like even your best one here
how to comment bucking horse in 30
minutes and ride him that's a great
title if anybody's dealing with a
bucking horse and like in 30 minutes I
can get an answer cool but I
you know that thumbnail is not great
right the horse does it is he bucking I
can't even tell if he's bucking he's no
not yet
so yeah well this or no this horse
didn't Buck thank goodness oh okay well
hopefully in our video somewhere here it
actually shows a bucking horse and how
to how to calm him down and get on but
honestly there hasn't been you put some
effort into this one for the thumbnail
which became your second best video
but all the other videos is no real oh
some of these I guess down here you've
done a little bit I've done a few yeah
on down at the bottom uh
yeah those two right there how to
control your horse
uh right down there uh says warming your
scared horse and human to horse
oh here yeah so the the bigger the text
the easier it is to read so how to
control your horse this is a lot easier
to read here
versus this it's all of that text is
really the worm how to warm a scared
horse it's really small text like
worming your scared horses kind of easy
to read but not compared to this right
high-headed horses that's a lot bigger
easier to read all the text underneath
it forget it you can't read that on most
people consume on the phone so they
can't read that okay and then the
picture uh are you are you you know I
guess I mean it's obviously it's you
with a horse but does it have anything
to do with warming or calming down a
third horse okay yeah that one does yeah
but these guys head up he's that's what
a horse usually does when they're scared
when you're when you're warming them
okay yeah
and in that 3L or whatever is at the
bottom is not it's not helpful for the
video
okay so I make the picture bigger even
this is a decent style where you've got
a picture and then text
just a picture of you with
with the horse and ideally something
that relates to the the video like
imagine if you took this and put it on
here where the picture is actually a
bucking horse
yeah and then
um the text said calm bucking horse or
the text said calm your horse
you just get a lot more people clicking
on it than
if it's I mean it's just a horse kind of
walking up to a barn
well on that particular one right there
that horse
was always throwing off the uh owners
and this is actually a 101. I forgot we
got a one-on-one program too where we'll
travel across country to to work with
problem horses and uh but the whole idea
is is I do some work with the horse
first on the ground and then I get in
the saddle and there's some things that
have to do in Saddle but I want to
prevent the horse from bucking at all
cool well just some kind of picture like
you've got great content here you're the
fact you have 50 000 views on this video
means that there's
there's good content Like Larry French
knows what he's talking about to help
you calm a bucking horse like this is a
it's a good quality video with the
content inside the problem is the
packaging so it's like you have a great
book
and no cover
all right so without the cover people
don't want to pick up the book so you
had a great title so this is good
but then the the picture itself if you
moved it to something like this and if
you look at all your videos and move
them to something like this you'd get
better results on your videos but
couldn't that one uh the high-headed
horses couldn't that be better could
should that be better than that or is
that I can always be better you know I
mean I'm always trying to beat my
thumbnails too they can always be better
okay but
in looking at your channel and looking
at how well some of these videos have
done
the fact you have 680 subscribers and
you have a bunch of videos that I
already have more than 600 views these
videos are helping you grow your Channel
uh
but they have no cover
yeah you know like you spend a little
bit of time on the on the title right
this this is not like horse video number
one you actually spent time on the title
but you haven't done any work on the
thumbnails for most of these
okay
I'll get that done yeah cool that's
exciting
you never know what you're gonna learn
when you open up a YouTube channel so
now we're learning about bucking horses
and deworming and all of this this is
great yeah yeah well thank you very much
I sure do like your program thank you
thank you Larry appreciate you man I
wanted to ask in regards of uh YouTube
to change the the name of the channel uh
seems like I had to wait for some time I
couldn't change it like right away I had
to wait for some time and uh my
reasoning was okay if I'm gonna change
the name of the channel I'm gonna stop
uh uploading videos because I don't know
what's gonna be the fact once I change
the name of the Channel with the videos
that are already there
um and uh how is that like it affects
somehow and also what's what's more
appealing to use the Immigrant mindset
or my immigrant mindset I Andrew
suggested that I should get the website
that comes I got the.com for my
immigrant mindset and and the that ca
for the Immigrant mindset those were
available okay so I'm still haven't
changed the the channel right now it's
called
um uh the Immigrant mindset but I was
thinking that maybe my immigrant mindset
was it's I don't know it's just a little
thing that I'm trying to figure out and
yeah it's not a big deal either way it's
such a minor change between the end so I
would not let that be a reason why
you're not making content I do have
videos ready to upload okay it's just
that I need to they didn't let me change
the name of the channel like I couldn't
like I'm not really that that good yet
to to to do all the stuff in the YouTube
in YouTube but I couldn't change the the
the name yet it seems like I I need to
have a period of time of waiting like a
month yeah I think it's 30 days every 30
days you can change it at the earliest
but you but you can still upload videos
while you're while you're waiting
there's no reason not to upload videos
and when I change the name all the all
the videos will be like it will not be
any effect on whatever I have there or
the views or the likes or whatever thing
no no it won't make a difference okay
and it's the same day immigrant or my
email like it's the same that like
nothing no no one is more there's no
more appealing name is like the same
either or
either one works they're pretty close I
mean my my first channel name I think
you can still find it is like is
modeling the Masters
I think on youtube.com
it'll still show up nobody really cares
or notices you know if you can get the
website that's a boost so if you already
have the my immigrantmindset.com the.com
is better than the dot CA I have that's
the ca I have the my immigrant.ca and I
have the the The Immigrant mind they
immigrant mindset.ca for the myimigrant
I have the.com yeah so the.com is better
okay okay if you put it around it just
helps with the brand more than having a
DOT ca for bigger things that you want
to do so it's not only limited to Canada
Americans don't really care about a DOT
CA or people around the world don't
really care about a DOT CA
um so but yeah it won't make a
difference on the channel more views
less views especially changing that's a
pretty minor change the to end so I
wouldn't worry and uh yeah keep posting
okay thank you very much yeah you got it
hey Evan I'll try a question and I think
you're focused on uh YouTube mostly here
for advice uh the best YouTube uh videos
I see have a lot of editing and some
strong stories short of doing all that
kind of editing what works well I know
you've done your you know walking down
the street kind of videos how how uh is
a talking head sufficient uh or does one
need to add some of those extra elements
to make the video more compelling yeah
and we don't only have to talk YouTube
like whatever people are what's ever on
your mind happy to go dive in
um For Thought leadership stuff the
editing is not the the biggest piece
it's still more about the like the first
minute really really matters so it's
still if you're doing thought leadership
like direct to camera the first sentence
you say really matters it's hooking
people in for the first minute just like
you would on a landing page a website an
email like the sentence matters the
first paragraph matters to hook people
to want to watch the rest of it so it
depends on what you want to sell if you
want to sell speaking engagements and
speaking Services I want to see Mark
Elwood the speaker then I need to see
you speak and
just start speaking just like hit me
with something what do you believe that
other people don't believe you don't
need fancy editing for that that's
quality of thought more than quality of
production but in a lot of speeches it's
still slow to get into it it's still
like or even like worst of the intros
hey I'm Evan and I do yada yada like
goodbye nobody's watching that so like
right away into your powerful opinion or
you do coaching where you're helping
people who who have productivity issues
um or whatever else you want to coach
people on and they come on and they
share what they're struggling with and
you you coach them through it but you
don't editing is
if you were to ask me in five years it
might be slightly different it's
starting to pick up but still it's
nobody's
you know they're not watching your
videos because there's a man climbing a
a rock in California with the sunrise
behind you with some fancy music like
they're watching your videos because
they're there to learn something
so I would focus and set on the editing
on on you and I mean you're a great
speaker so just honing in
the very beginning that first minute
really really capturing your attention
to make it make it matter
the poll question was from Michael who
said owning your time and schedule so
my quick take on this and then we'll get
to you know questions from you guys
whatever I can help answer in this
little mini break for us today
um I love energy zones I think I think
staying in the same energy Zone really
really really matters so today is
Thursday uh all of my public facing
stuff is on a Thursday I had I start
with movement makers which always gets
me I'm an introvert right so I don't
wake up and like hey Michael Jordan just
in time we're doing your question right
now Michael drive safe though drive safe
um we uh you know I get so much love
from Movie Makers that that gets me
fired up for the rest of the day and so
all I have to do on a Thursday is do my
public facing stuff so all day long it's
just interviews and and sessions like
this and podcasts and better Movie
Makers and then three podcasts and then
this and then like four more podcasts
and then live streaming tonight but I'm
not worried about my YouTube channel I'm
not worried about my team I'm not
worried about anything else besides just
spreading the message today and I think
it's great to stay in that energy Zone
because the energy I got from Movie
Makers I'm still pouring into the next
group and the love I get from you guys
I'm pointing to my podcast right after
this and so I don't have to switch I
think switching between different tasks
ends up being really really it's
challenging for everybody maybe extra
challenging for me
um because I think to spend half an hour
on a podcast and then 20 minutes writing
the book and then 40 minutes doing
something else you end up just getting
nothing done you feel like if you ever
felt like I worked all day but I got
nothing done
it's probably because you're switching
between energy states too much and so
all I have to worry about today is this
one thing of spreading the message
um
yesterday was my project day
so this this is a change that I made in
the past year or year and a half that
really made a huge impact was adding
project day in the middle so Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Tuesday is my YouTube
day it's crazy it's crazy it's just I
gotta make videos for 12 different
channels plus two strategy plus it's
just all day long if you're on my team
don't try to reach me on a Tuesday it's
not going to happen I'm just making
videos
Thursdays today is crazy crazy just all
day long interviews and podcasts and
Skypes and just all day long so in the
middle Wednesday is open day Wednesday
is my project day Wednesday I wake up
I'm like what do I want to work on today
um it doesn't turn into like let's play
League of Legends all day like I like
working but I get to basically pick
whatever project I want to work on and I
like having a freedom
in the middle of the week between the
two crazy days it used to be like write
my book day right you know if I'm right
in the book I need a whole day it's hard
to write a book in 20 minutes a day
because it takes you 20 minutes just to
get back into what you were doing any
kind of creative work if you're doing
creative work you need like chunks of
time without the stress of I need to be
done by one o'clock so I can go off and
do this thing that kills your creativity
so Wednesday's creative work day
um and I'm just trying to get way way
way way way way more stuff done working
the same number of hours but just way
more productive because I'm not shifting
my energy too much now you may not be in
complete control of your day you might
have a job you might have customers you
might have other responsibilities family
whatever so whatever is inside your
calendar that you can control just being
more intentional with it
and making sure that what's in your
calendar is going to help you get your
goals right like if you want to have a
YouTube channel I was talking about just
before this was on a podcast with the
guys like help me build my YouTube
channel okay great well show me where in
your calendar have you dedicated time to
make YouTube videos
oh I haven't done that well that's why
you're not making YouTube videos dude
it doesn't ever happen it's like yeah
that's why I haven't made a video in the
past three months okay great so it's
it's we can change that we can add that
we can put it in
um but your actions have to be you know
map to your Ambitions what's in your
calendar has to be the thing that you're
working towards every day so I like
different days for different things I
have my morning routine which I do every
day and then I fall into whatever that
day is going to be so mentoring day
Monday YouTube day Tuesday uh
Wednesday's open project Day creative
day Thursdays public facing day
interviews Friday is CEO day grow the
business Saturday is fun day
and then Sunday's family admin day and
even that's an important distinction
Sunday is
go grocery shopping do the laundry
uh
uh whatever I mean whatever has to get
done clean up the condo
you know all the all the stuff that you
have to do to live life that is not fun
but that's kind of required be honest on
a Sunday but it's not on Saturday
I'm not folding laundry on a Saturday
Saturday is the only day where we don't
even do I don't even do the dishes you
normally my wife cooks and I do the
dishes after not Saturday Saturday
I'll leave the dishes for Sunday
like Saturday is fun day and it's
important I think to put up the the
blocks on your calendar to more not just
like what you are going to do but what
you're not going to do
I'm not going to
get interrupted by my team today I am
not going to work on my YouTube channel
today I am not going to and I think that
that really helps you stay a lot more
focused
and then my last is quick thought and
then we can open up if you want me to go
in deeper and Michael know you're here
so if you got questions on that just
kind of top level but it also lets you
miss the work I like to miss the work
like you guys we see each other once a
week now it's like I miss you guys in
between
yeah it's like we get this and then
tomorrow I'm not missing you but then
come like Tuesday Wednesday like when we
get the readers group and then Thursday
comes you're like Hey we're back
so if you only do something once a week
you're always missing it when it comes
up
so I haven't made YouTube videos since
Tuesday I'm not missing it yet but come
like Friday Saturday it's like oh I want
to make I want to make some YouTube
videos so whatever day I'm about to jump
into I'm always missing the work as
opposed to kind of getting bored
overwhelmed or whatever from it
um so that's really helped me and again
you may not be able to control your
whole day
but whatever you can control just being
intentional with it and asking yourself
hey over the next week I've got seven
days and inside inside of that I've got
14 hours that I can play with how am I
going to use those 14 hours
that are my time to be able to move
closer to achieving the goals I've got
for myself
that's my quick my quick take Michael to
help you guys got extra questions you
want to dive deeper on it I got another
question
can I ask yeah yeah Michael then we'll
go to we'll go to Nile that's how his
hand up too what do you got okay uh uh
so at the end of the day do you have a
time that you stop with your work and
then that's your family time time to
spend with your kid uh or with the wife
or are you like until you go to bed uh
like you're on making videos until 8 p.m
and then you do your bedtime routine and
go to bed
so if I look at a normal breakdown
um with kind of family time so we'll
I'll go for a walk with my wife in the
morning so I'll take the dogs out then
we'll go for a walk and we spend the
first 45 minutes to an hour of the day
kind of just setting up for the day
we're both not mourning people so at the
beginning we're not really talking
it's kind of like holding hands and
walking outside
uh and then as like the Sun hits you and
the fresh air we start
having a conversation hey how's it
what's up for today how'd you sleep last
night and just kind of I like walking in
the day with some fresh air and not just
being inside all the time
um especially now with everything going
on it's like we don't get enough
outside stuff that we get to do
um then usually we'll take a break at 2
30.
uh we both have that under count it was
a break for half an hour 2 30 to connect
it could be
um
depending on how we're feeling it could
be another like quick outside just take
the dog to the park super quick come
back up but that kind of built into our
schedule
um
after that I'll go back to work uh
usually until at least five five to six
is like my buffer zone for anything
urgent
so
you know today is my interview day I
actually have a gap from five to six but
I put that in because we booked so far
in advance for guests for my me to be on
shows that if something really urgent
comes up I hate having to post postpone
somebody or cancel on somebody like
worst case we can but if some big
opportunity comes up we have that as our
buffer zone just kind of like hotels off
in the the penthouse suite is open just
in case some big person comes in there's
there's a room for them they have to
kick somebody out
um 6 to 7 30 ish I'm doing my live
stream usually four days a week with Zan
here and and Drew and then from 7 30 to
what nine
uh it's usually playing with the kids
uh right now we're doing a lot of
Minecraft together uh because three
different cities you know nieces and
nephews all that stuff we just join on
the Minecraft server together I'm not
very good at Minecraft
um but whatever it's a fun thing to do
and I think there's a lot of actual life
lessons that happen like if you go and
you build your character in Minecraft
and then you step into lava and you lose
all your stuff do you rage quit and
freak out or can you talk that through
right and like I think you can parent
and teach and life lessons through
everything and the more you're doing
things that they like as opposed to like
forcing to do what you want
um there's actually better teaching
there
nine to ten Nina and I usually watch a
show right now we're watching Homeland
uh we're on the last season of Homeland
working our way through usually we're
watching like some of the superhero
movies or shows uh Legends of tomorrow
and what else we watch Green Arrow
uh anyway there was this big gap of no
shows coming out it's like oh we got
nothing to watch so we fell into home
line and that's pretty good
um but that's one hour
then I wash the dishes take the dogs out
um answer the questions I do like 10
questions 11. and then we get ready for
bed
um
so that's a typical like Monday to
Friday kind of day Friday night would
probably just stay up a little bit later
and do stuff together but that's a
typical weekday so uh there's a morning
time there's an afternoon time when
there's an evening time
um spread out between like just the two
of us or time with family too so far
works but it's constant like Minor
Adjustments as we go Nile what you got
hey can you hear me today yeah we got
you yeah excellent yes hey your wall is
basically the same as mine dude it's
just it's it's orange I don't mine's
orange yours is coming through with red
yours it kind of looks red just a little
lighter but I like it dude this is great
thanks and listen I have been I haven't
had a chance to speak this is fantastic
at what you're doing here and um I think
this is great and everything that people
share is fantastic you mind if I take it
off topic just for a little bit from the
scheduling or do you want to focus you
know whatever whatever you guys want one
quick question I had was what would you
suggest or what's your thought on
building a brand on you as a person
compared to building a brand around an
entity or a company name or a theme
person's always easier okay your story
is your greatest Advantage right why is
somebody going to buy from you versus
some giant Corporation because they feel
like you actually care about them
but where you lose is you don't have the
history you don't have the reputation
you don't have the name brand yet you
think about whoever the biggest
competitors are in your industry like
why it's the old expressive nobody got
fired for buying IBM
um like the big brands that they're
trusted so they may not treat you super
well but at least you know what you're
getting and they have a history and
they're likely not going to screw you
over
um so if you're if you're a logo
you're basically taking the worst of
Both Worlds where if you make it your
personal brand they may not they may not
know you yet but it's like man this guy
cares
that's why sharing your story right I
mean
why emphasize so much in here is sharing
your story matters is what makes people
connect to you that okay maybe you don't
have the history of the reputation yet
but man I feel like this guy actually
cares about me and I wanna I wanna
I want to do business with him and how
about sorry out of the theme itself uh
Builds on and stems from my story and
how I could further serve that's that's
where I'm thinking of going I've just
reincarnated myself but I rebranded
myself but it wasn't it's not me
necessarily it's me I'm all that's on on
my branding but it's backed by a mantra
and that that has to tie to your your
purpose of course yeah that's why you
tell your story because that's who
you're trying to help in reading your
story I need to feel like oh my God this
guy gets me right this guy is exactly
who I am and I need I need his help like
you're you're a hundred steps ahead but
you're the same person and so I can
learn from you because
you get me that's your biggest Advantage
your story is your biggest Advantage as
an entrepreneur right right I just
didn't know if it would be possession
from hey Nile it's me or the concept of
my brand not the concept but the
positioning of my brain so it it opens
up something that becomes familiar
um very similar to your your one word
that's that's where yeah like you are
your brand right right so it's not this
is then this is what happened with your
one word and then build the service
believe isn't just a strategy for me
I am believe it's my who same thing for
all you guys like when you figure out
your who it's who you are and you show
up
everywhere as that so I I right now I'm
believing in you guys and I'm believing
all the people that I'm doing shows with
afterwards but when I when I come home
and still believe it's still spreading
belief to my wife and my family it's
it's it takes on a different life right
I'm not telling Nina go make your
YouTube content and spread your message
but it's still you know believing in her
so it's not just a hat that you wear
it's actually who you are so Nile equals
blank not just oh this is my business
stands for this but I stand for
something different
right perfect thank you
varindra yeah yeah and that's right
Yvonne thank you thank you thank you for
having these sessions uh wonderful to
have you thanks a lot first of all and
uh hi everyone my question is on this
point you just mentioned about the one
word so I got your one word book now so
reading through it but if you get kind
of help in terms of how we find it and
will be
uh you know get that through quickly so
we can start more
did you go through the five questions
of like your favorite teacher I I have
just started reading you yesterday of me
so I have got to that point the chapter
two where the five questions are there
so I'll be going to answer them okay so
that that honestly that's the best thing
like go through the questions the both
books were not designed as just uh
read the book and put it away it's like
it's it's a you have to think you have
to do the exercises you know it's a it's
almost a workbook inside a book
um if you want to get the value out of
it I think the best thing is go through
the questions and if you get stuck
come back next week and and we'll
Workshop it
okay yeah fine thank you
I saw a lady had her hand up lady Alexey
I'm trying to figure out how to work my
schedule uh as in uh recording videos
and all the other stuff ever since I've
been dealing with the death of my mom
and my kids and I'm swamped by
whether it's an appointment with the
attorney cleaning up the house
um you name it real estate agents of
course my brother my sister but you know
I have limited amount of energy I have
to juggle through it all so you were
talking about your schedule during the
day and I'm like okay how would I be
able to maintain some sort of schedule
uh along with the regular clients I've
got and and trying to get my story
online that's actually why I didn't
record because I was so tired at night
so you know there are moments where you
need to give yourself more grace right
and and you know sorry to hear about
your mom and your cat and
um you know we lost our family dog uh
not too long ago and
uh some people you know see that as
mushy or whatever but that's a big deal
like it's part of your family
um we also lost uh my sister-in-law last
year at the end of the year
um like 40 years old I did some super
rare cancer three kids
um one teen and two pre-teens and that
uh
that took us all out
you know I was not being nearly as
productive as I could have been
um
uh I wasn't doing as many shows as I
usually had my Wednesday or Friday might
have been completely gone instead of
doing creative work I'm spending the
time with my nieces or nephews just
not even doing much is being with them
because their mom just died and what do
you do as an eight-year-old right just
to have some kind of
love their um they're still you know
they were trying to figure out school
they're no school and just dealing with
it
um so this Grace you know there are some
moments in life where you have to give
yourself a little bit more grace and
understand that you're not going to be
at your regular capacity when I broke my
neck you know
that was brutal
but I still made videos every day you
know I think like having something that
you can hang your hat on to
to even if you're even if you're tired
even if you're not 100 just to look back
and say like I'm still not giving up on
my ambitions
so whatever that looks like for you
like if making videos is really
important to you I would still make
videos and post like you can make a five
minute video I made a video from my
hospital bed with my broken neck and a
concussion
and
Doug Wilder is not here in the house
right now but he took a screenshot of it
and it looks like I'm dead
I mean it's probably just a bad
screenshot too but I've got my neck
brace on like this giant scab across my
forehead and it was definitely not
anywhere close to being my best content
but I'm you know looking back super
proud that I still did it
to do the difficult thing when it's hard
it was my best content it was a five
minute video instead of I committed to
going live every day
right while I was on my tour and
everybody
yeah
so it's it's okay to to let go of the
structure you know with opinion and all
that stuff and just post like one minute
videos and
you know without the beginning and the
ends you know the bumper and food are
let go of all that
at the end of the day all that matters
is how proud are you of yourself
are you proud that you did the best that
you could give him what you had
so if you're gonna say hey I can either
not make a video because it's not
perfect or I can make a one minute video
with everything else going on but it
won't have the structure
I'd rather you make the one minute video
I I did record them I just didn't post
them more yeah and I did write notes so
I would like to go in it you know after
all
post and then recognize now if it's a
year later and you're still
here that's a problem right so like
there's a grace period and grief is real
right but if it's three years later and
you're still in grief and you still
can't do anything then that's that's a
bigger problem that we need to to work
through but for the most part I think of
all the negative emotions
you know if you think positive emotions
like courage and ambition and drive and
service and all that and negative
emotions of of fear and anger and
jealousy and all of that
every negative emotion I want to try to
eliminate from my life except for grief
grief is a special one like I don't want
to have jealousy in my life I don't want
to have anger or or
um any of the like strong negative
emotions but grief not that I want grief
in my life but it's it it just has to be
worked through
like if I'm jealous about somebody I
don't want to work I want to fix it and
get rid of it I don't want to be jealous
of other people but grief you can't just
get rid of it like if you dive into your
work
it's still there
you know you can't just forget about it
and so you have to work through it and
time will heal and you won't be as
productive as you could be normally
would be and that's fine there's a
little bit of Grace I think all of us
and if you haven't had any grief yet
it's it's going to happen at some point
I mean it's just the Human Experience oh
I I did I did have it and of course I
still go to to syrupy like two times a
week for my ankles so you know it's
juggling with limited amounts of energy
but I I also noticed that I really want
to continue on with the business the
drive is there
so release make your one minute videos
and release it
okay thank you
Andrew is just raising his hand normally
so we could start with Andrew I um I'm
super pumped to ask this question
because you actually posted about it
recently on your Instagram so it's okay
it's good timing I really have you
changed your uh setup a little bit the
background's a little different than
usual no no oh
um I was in Montreal I was staying in
Montreal I'm back uh just outside of
Ottawa right now okay I'm a digital
Nomad I kind of float around and uh and
so yeah that's why my background changes
all right uh a really uh appreciated
your Instagram post recently where you
took a snapshot of the I believe it was
the lifetime of your YouTube channel and
you pointed out that the importance of
picking the right partner and how
they're picking the right partner will
uh contribute to your success and that
perfectly ties into what I wanted to ask
you today how uh how did you manage the
conversation with your wife as far as
and I'm gonna try to word this as best I
can I hope hope this makes sense uh with
regards to how visible your lifestyle is
and how you put yourself out there and
you welcome the spotlight you're an
introvert just like myself but you
welcome the spotlight some spouses some
partners are going to be okay and
they're going to be comfortable with
that others are not going to be okay
with that I'm curious if you could touch
on that how did that conversation go uh
and how did she respond or did you guys
actively talk about it or did it just
kind of organically happen
that's what I'm looking for yeah so it
was an evolution even for myself to to
show more personal stuff was an
evolution if you go back on my early
videos there's not a ton about you know
my life or my travels or whatever so it
it was an evolution
um with Nina
she or I mean I already had my YouTube
channel so she knew I did YouTube videos
uh she
there was no big conversation there was
no sit-down moment to be like okay
we have to discuss what we're gonna do
um
at the beginning when she saw me making
videos she would every now and then pop
in the background wave do something
behind my back that I didn't even know
she was doing just to photobomb my
videos
and then you watch the replayer you see
the comments oh we love Nina's like what
did Nina do and then you see it like the
four minute Mark she did something in
the background
um and she slowly became more
comfortable in terms of being on camera
so then she went from like a little
Cameo behind to then just saying
something to then now she does a bunch
of the like any video that's an Evan top
10 she records the whole thing herself
that just became
an evolution and
it got to the point where like she's
she's for the Vlog Channel going her to
go get a facial done and going in with
no makeup and then you come out of a
facial and your face is all purple and
whatever right and she's like she's
filming all that in in her friend saying
hey don't you like
aren't you scared to be on camera like
that and she's like I don't know I guess
I was but I just kind of got used to it
um so that being said
my parents for example are very private
people
and and they're never on camera
and any if I was if I'm going to their
house to celebrate something you might
see you know an Instagram picture of the
cake for whoever's birthday or whatever
but you never see them uh and that also
was in a conscious like sit-down
conversation to say okay guys I'm on
YouTube now
do you want to be my videos or not
um my parents have had a huge impact on
my life I mean they're behind me on the
wall right there but you only know three
to eight different stories about them
that I've shared because they're very
private people so you get to you get the
pick
you don't have to be
public with all of your information you
get to pick what you share and I'm
always just trying to bounce with the
people who
um
the people who I'm bringing on stream
are bringing on the video to understand
what do they want what are they
comfortable with uh you can sit down and
have a conversation but uh for me it was
just rolling with it
um you know I see Zane the man here
who's uh been an active part of my my
stream for the gaming channel and we've
had some very
uh in-depth
discussions why don't we call it
on the gaming channel and and most of
the stuff is open you know for anybody
to watch and it in Zane's Journey uh
other people can learn and be inspired
as well you know and we've also had you
know private thing last week we had a
private call to go deeper into some of
the things that okay you know what like
here's the line of what we're gonna
share and not share with like the whole
world to watch your business and evolve
so let's let's spend some time like dive
into that part that you may not want to
share
um his wife came on right and I got to
meet her which was amazing but she's not
involved in the live stream you might
see an arm every now and then pop
through the door but she's not involved
in that
um so it's really just paying attention
to
the person and what they're comfortable
with I would say Nina's case so being
super introverted never wanted to be a
YouTuber uh she grew into it and she
likes it and that evolved you know for
her uh my son from the beginning is like
yeah YouTube let's go I can't wait give
me a camera I'm at you know so you just
you just you bounce with it thank you I
really appreciate your feedback on that
because everyone seems to have their own
methods uh garyvee garyvee famously
never includes his wife or his kids in
anything I I don't know anyone who knows
uh what his wife and kids look like
because he actively avoids creating
content with them so I was just curious
what your take was on that so thanks so
much for sharing that Dougie fresh has a
question what do we got Doug
my question is your purpose from your
pain it's one of the favorite sayings
that that I've adopted from you
um
how do you deal with
I
and I'm kind of asking a a general
question but how do you deal with
getting over embarrassment like if it's
something that's very
uh sticky or something like that you
just you just say you know
screw it because I know I'm going to
help somebody else out or what can you
walk walk me through some more of that
yeah so for me I'll split it between
like is it me who's embarrassed or is it
Nina who might be embarrassed so my
parents might be embarrassed right that
if it's me then I want to lean into it
if it's my parents or Nina or somebody
else then that would cause me some pause
for sure and I probably wouldn't do it
um
I think the more you can lean into your
embarrassment you realize that it
actually releases the embarrassment
like by actually sharing it when you can
turn it to service for others
um the story that I usually tell is uh I
was at Tony Robbins event
and
they had the security guard detail
and they rotate because the Tony Robbins
event is like 12 hours a day for four
days or whatever it's crazy and Tony
invited me as his personal guest so I'm
sitting there in the front row
um with my friend Mark and what I
noticed was every seven to ten minutes
the security guards would shift so
they're not always sitting in the same
spot for 12 hours and anytime they did a
shift they would fist bump the next
person it's really like low-key not like
Hi-Fi fist bump just like boom fist bump
rotate take your seat go to the next guy
so I get this idea
I'm gonna fist bump the security guard
as they come by
I want to fist bump them too just thank
them for their service you know so like
you know the first guy comes fist bump
great at the time I put my hand out he
looks at my hand and keeps walking
it's like oh my God I just got I just
got owned by the security guard of the
Tony Robbins event you got iced I got
ice I got Isis like man I I can't
believe it I got shunned and my first my
first my first thought was because in my
head was of course he's gonna fist bump
me why not write a Tony Robbins event
you know this is what it's all about
my first thought was who just saw me get
massively embarrassed right there was
the first like oh my God I just got
ice is that even a thing ice I think ice
would be like you got killed but I don't
know I just got I just got owned by this
guy and and I my first thought was I I'm
massively embarrassed right now and who
saw me now in the grand scheme of things
like who can nobody even cares right I
mean
they're not focused on me and me trying
to fist bump the security guard looking
at Tony here on stage but in my head
this is what this is what uh goes on Zen
says disc yeah I just got dissed by the
guy
um so then
yeah I was I was cycling through and now
I'm not paying attention to Tony Robbins
anymore because I'm so worried about me
getting dissed by this guy and who saw
it uh but then the thing that shifted it
was
I'm going if somebody saw that and
laughed at me for doing it uh great what
I'm gonna do now is I'm gonna keep doing
it until I get a fist bump
so that becomes now if anybody was
watching me now it's inspiration because
if they see me keep getting dissed pass
pass he's still doing it he's still
doing it he's still going how they start
cheering for me at least again nobody
probably even saw or cared but this is a
story inside her own mind the thing
you're embarrassed about
um a lot of the things that we're
embarrassing about aren't that big a
deal to other people they're dealing
with their own problems their own pain
and own suffering in their own battles
and Wars so then the next guy comes and
you know I do the same thing the next
guy disses me too and like doesn't looks
at the hand and just keeps walking by
oh my gosh Come on this is now the
second person here now I'm full on in
just I need to get this to happen I'm
not paying attention at all to what
Tony's saying on stage in the front row
and the next person comes in and now I'm
trying to I'm trying to make eye contact
with him I'm trying to like laugh you
know just before so that when he comes
I'm not just some stranger that it's
gonna happen
um
and so the next he can't you know the
rotate comes and I put up my fist bump
and and he fist bumped me back subtle
Loki and then like I'm like yes
20 minutes of Tony Robbins content it
doesn't matter because I got a fist bump
from the security guard
but the thing that again the the initial
embarrassment
as soon as you can flip with the service
it gets rid of the embarrassment because
now you're helping other people so
whatever your yesterday I was doing an
interview with Deepak Chopra in in nine
minutes before I'm I'm my heart's
beating I'm like I'm scared like oh my
god I've never talked to Deepak so I
don't know his messaging fully in my
heart's beating I want to have a good
interview and what I did was I went to
Instagram to share it it's like hey I'm
I'm nine minutes from Showtime from
Deepak showing up and us doing this show
and I'm I'm nervous my heart's beating
super quick but we do difficult things
let's go
well and in the flipping it to service
eliminated the embarrassment
and gives you the courage to go to the
thing that you need to do
for your own cheerleader
yeah I mean I guess but it's still more
like I want to help somebody else I want
somebody to see me somebody could look
at me like oh he's interviewed all these
people and so it's just so easy for him
I want them to see the struggle that
goes on just before and the willingness
to then do the courageous thing to
hopefully Inspire somebody else to
do their version of it not that they
have to go interview Deepak but whatever
their version of the thing is
right like when you talked about
interviewing uh Matthew McConaughey you
watched a bunch of his interviews to ask
him something different
yeah and I was I was more scared even
for McConaughey than for Deepak because
I knew zero about McConaughey besides
him being an actor
and I didn't want to go on an interview
and say so
what's it like being an actor just some
useless question right
um
yeah so flip at the service like it's
it's yes being your own cheerleader of
doing a difficult thing but recognize
that whatever you're so embarrassed by
there are many many many many many many
many many people who who are embarrassed
by the same thing
and if you stay silent it perpetuates
the silence
if you come up and say hey this thing
happened to me or I did this and I'm not
proud of it it brings it into the open
and other people can heal as you heal as
well great thank you so much come in all
right Joy what do we got I see the hand
so you were talking about how it was
hard to interview you get nervous so I'm
wondering
um so what do you do when you're gonna
be with that person and it's not an
interview and you're just hanging out
like if you meet up somewhere or you're
doing a project together how does that
work
if you're super nervous to interview
them how do you take that into just
being in their presence and being a
person with them
so I usually don't just hang out I suck
at hanging out
[Laughter]
you're like working on something uh so
the most recent example of that because
you know with covid we haven't I haven't
left my home to go to any event for a
long time but
just before covet started I was in
Puerto Rico with a bunch of the the big
names of Brandon burchard and negraziosi
and you know Lewis house and Jay Shetty
and all those people and
um there was a format of
Mastermind Roundtable so there's maybe
25 of us at a table at Brendan's house
and
everybody got a chance to talk about
what over over three days everybody had
a chance to go and talk about what
they're working on and how to what they
need help with
and that's fine that's easy right it's
like okay you've got a problem great
tell me your problem let's let's try to
help and dissect and bring value but
then there were long breaks where you
just hang out
where it's like okay go grab lunch or go
just take a break and it's two hours
later until you sit back down at the
table and everything inside of me was
like okay I just want to go back to my
room because I hate just hanging out
without an agenda or like even know what
we're talking about
um
but what I did was I forced myself to
say no you know what I'm I'm here this
is hard for me
I'm I can still help even though there's
no kind of fixed agenda I'm gonna go in
and try to make it work and I'm not the
most gregarious or outgoing person I see
a group of four people I'm not going to
go in and say hey guys I'm Evan you know
what are you doing
um but I'm typical Evan would have gone
back to the hotel room and just come
back two hours later for everything and
so I said no I'm I'm gonna do what's
difficult for me and I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm going to inject myself in the
conversations and try to make things
work
um was it the best no were the more you
know you look at Lewis house for example
who was there and Louis will talk to
anybody about anything Lewis is just
fantastic that way right like hey I'm
Louis what do you do and just
immediately go into conversation uh so
Lewis is talking up a storm everywhere
and I did the best that I could at the
time with what I had and I'm really
proud of
that was difficult for me even though it
might have been super easy for Lewis
so I don't often find myself in those
situations because I don't usually like
to just hang out
it's actually based around a project so
there's some kind of agenda and we're
working towards something I work with a
lot of these guys on different projects
but again you know we've got a clearly
defined project of what we're working on
but when I am in a situation like that
it's okay I want to do the thing that
will make me proud and here here comes a
learning opportunity
let's go
cool
thank you cool no problem let's see we
got time for one more bork did I
pronounce it properly
angelic music we made it happen does it
work
well
if you're if you're real French then
it's Burke but okay my mother my
mother's family has always called it
Burke Burke yeah okay I have a question
yes my
I I don't know how to deal with this but
I I don't want to be
like rude because all of a sudden we've
we've moved back to Calgary from New
York because New York was just really
really really weird the last months and
so we moved back here and my mother I've
become this much much much comfortable
with myself I am I am I'm not an
introvert and I'm really happy with that
because I like talking to people and all
that and I'm
but my mother keeps looking at me and
going shhh
and it's like
I don't want to be embarrassed of myself
and she makes me it's like all this like
Ugh
it makes me just want to move back to
our place that we're still renting in
New York
I mean at some point it's figuring out
when are you living your life right
exactly when are you an adult and and
for some people they're 75 years old and
still listen to their 95 year old
parents uh has what they can and can't
do I think an element of like if you're
in your your parents home or somebody
else's home there is an element of kind
of respect for their rules and and
what's going on
um we're not
we're we're like half an hour walk away
yeah so honestly then it's just limiting
limiting the exposure yeah right so like
some some topics are awful I'm sure you
love your mom and I'm sure there's a lot
of great things you can talk about and
it's it's cut enough access to the
things that bother you I mean I think to
some point you can't have a discussion I
just it's it's unlikely that it's Gonna
Change very much yeah to say Hey you
know when you shush me it makes me feel
really disrespected uh you feels like
you're shutting me down and I don't have
my own voice I bet that uh may do
something but likely won't it's it's
having empathy and compassion for her
well she's 90.
well it's like listen uh at some point I
mean I had to go through my grandfather
having Alzheimer's
uh which is just
a terrible thing to go through terrible
and and they slowly become
um
just
almost like a baby right right can't
remember anything reminding them you
know they don't know who you are all of
this stuff and so I mean
thank God she still has her mental
faculties enough to even even tell you
shush
um but she's one of the smartest people
I know but just empathy for empathy for
her life and where she's at and her
situation and how she was raised because
it was a different era than what you
know you were raised at and even as a
mental prep before going in it's I
wouldn't even see it as I'm silencing
myself around her
um
you have lots of opportunities to be
yourself and express and share your
voice and and be you it's more
um
creating a gift for her to try to create
as great a relationship as possible
uh for the years that you guys both have
left together
yeah
okay so that's yeah that's that's that's
that's that's that's a good one
so congratulations on everything you've
done thank you thank you for the love
I'm excited to be here it's great to
have you thank you guys for the love
continue to believe and we'll see you
again very soon if you want to get a
copy of build to serve and join us live
for our next training with me to ask
your questions you can go get the book
right there next to me right there I'll
see you there I'll see you to get the
book it's a good one much love